all right Camila did you ever do anything when
you're a kid like make did I do anything to make
movies make movies I am I am I have lost my
laptop that had my photo booth on it uh in my
early teenage years and I don't know where it
is it's voted with a not Tick Tock wow well I
don't know what's on there for like a five-year
period of my life and I've lost it but I just
I just imagine like that I just remember being
like I was like a sad sad girl like like a Lana
Del Rey no no I was I would put it on I do like
I would do like sad music videos like looking out
like the window and it was raining so dramatic
listening to Lana Del Rey and being like yeah
my life is sweet like cinnamon I just had like
simply emotional YouTube uh photo booth videos
yeah and I don't know where they are today I
did that to tattoo but I was older than you
oh yeah oh my God I remember photo booths there
was Lana Del Rey there was like a lot of like we
were just in our feelings and like as like a 13
year old girl puberty it's hard oh yeah she was
this was my Alanis Morissette that was my that was
yeah and I was like wait women can say this yeah
I was like people are in the South aren't allowed
to say this if you're a girl um love her [Music]
foreign
[Applause] foreign